[Music]
on this saturday night
police move in respect me right to
protest for right now
the effort to clear the clog and get
goods moving across the ambassador
bridge again freedom
overwhelmed in ottawa
police outnumbered as protesters tear
down fencing at the national war
memorial the phone call that could stop
a war we continue to see
very troubling signs of russian
escalation world leaders engage in
last-minute negotiations over ukraine
and a breakthrough in treating spinal
injuries giving patients the ability to
walk again
global national
reporting tonight
chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
the clearing has begun police are moving
in to enforce a court order against
protesters at the ambassador bridge
blockade they've disrupted north
america's busiest international crossing
for six days now some have left but
others are digging in
a state of emergency is in effect in
ontario with demonstrations also
underway at the peace bridge in fort
erie
and in ottawa thousands gathered in the
downtown core at the national war
memorial and for a counter protest
that's starting to pick up steam
but we begin tonight in windsor where
shawn o'shea has been in the thick of it
as officers move in to clear that clog
sean
chris after almost a week of chaos this
police action was supposed to get things
back to normal in windsor but at this
point it hasn't
hours after a judge ordered these
protesters to leave they defiantly
stayed on into a sixth day but
supporters knew their time was up
they've tried to negotiate
when the time comes when it's all said
and done hopefully like i said
everything goes peaceful just after
sunrise police moved in
dozens of officers from around ontario
and the rcmp were brought in
the ontario provincial police and rcmp
had their tactical vehicles for backup
police surrounded the first group
occupying the bridge the most
significant trade link between canada
and the united states spotters kept
watch from above
all as some protesters tried to convince
police they shouldn't be doing this are
you gonna start believing in you
when and when they have to get their
tenth shot i hope they they stand up and
they're by themselves
all week these protesters said that if
police came they wouldn't leave but when
push came to shove that's exactly what
they've done police wanted everyone to
leave
[Music]
the news media ordered back too
leave these media outside the line
media out there let's go and again
canadian media outlets heard this from
some protesters you fake news get the
[ __ ] out of here then clearing the
blocked area was a time-consuming
operation police worked slowly and
carefully impeded by others who showed
up to lend their voice to the
demonstration when force forces you
you don't have a choice you know
the bullies run our lives
and police here in windsor still have a
problem on their hands more than eight
hours after they started to clear things
out more supporters have gone down to
the roadway near the bridge meaning at
this point that bridge remains closed
chris
thanks sean that's sean o'shea in
windsor
now day 16 of what the prime minister
and police are calling an illegal
occupation in our nation's capital all
available officers are being deployed to
enforce safety and encourage protesters
to leave but the disruption continues
crowds swelled in ottawa's downtown core
again and as abigail beeman reports the
national war memorial has once again
become a flashpoint
a group of protesters many appear to be
veterans wearing military attire
dismantle fencing surrounding the war
memorial fencing put up after this scene
during the first weekend of the protest
police are still investigating
[Music]
as the crowd around the memorial swelled
on saturday at first only a couple of
police officers were visible outnumbered
they talked to the dismantlers about
their cause a statement saying to the
politicians that
the soldiers don't see in them are
representatives because
we're portraying our country at this
point in time
protesters cleared the steps of snow and
yelled to watch out for the flowers
placed there good point we're going to
be back at the same point where people
are now going to
uh cause damage because unless you guys
are here 24 7.
i actually don't think that would be the
people that cause damage it's going to
be justin trudeau's gang of thieves yes
and if we got to put a man on this
because you guys have what like a
thousand cops in the city right now so
that's not what you guys think so we'll
put a man on it next one this is all you
guys
the veterans affairs minister called
what happened completely unacceptable
ottawa police wouldn't answer any of our
questions about it but they did speak to
the theme of being outnumbered in a
release earlier saturday they said they
have a plan to end what they're calling
an illegal occupation but they need more
reinforcements to carry it out everybody
is here peacefully protesters in ottawa
have been watching a different scene in
windsor where enforcement to move people
out began saturday morning no one we
spoke to seems worried i honestly want
to see every all the protesters on their
knees with their hands up getting
arrested right because we're here
peacefully for my nephew's freedom for
the next generation of kids freedom
i'll take a fine i'll get arrested i'm
not afraid police say 2600 tickets have
been issued and they've made 26 arrests
with 140 criminal investigations
underway as many call for tougher action
with thousands in the streets of the
nation's capital for the third weekend
in a row abigail beeman global news
ottawa
hundreds of people mostly ottawa
residents took to the streets to march
against the convoy protest the counter
protesters gathered in a park south of
downtown carrying messages like bullies
go home and make ottawa boring again
they say the goal is to have their
voices heard so they can get their city
back
somebody has to be here and
i think this is a productive
and loving
way to just to show our outrage and our
love for our city and honestly i
am appalled at the appropriation of our
flag
what i want to see is a truck of the
canadian flag and not be frightened
anymore
another common comment at the
demonstration is for order to be
restored to the capitol's downtown with
the convoy protest now dragging into its
third week
demonstrations in solidarity with those
in ottawa have formed in sites across
the country
[Applause]
hundreds gathered in toronto's downtown
court today gathering on the grounds of
the ontario legislature in a preemptive
move though police expanded road
closures in the area forcing protesters
to park and then walk in
and large crowds marched through the
streets of montreal calling for an end
to covet 19 measures
just as that province relaxes rules on
home gathering limits and restaurant
seating
protesters were invited to join the
convoy headed to ottawa after the event
and a group of counter protesters also
held their own march in the city
[Music]
and a new convoy formed in british
columbia's fraser valley this afternoon
with the goal of reaching the crucial
pacific highway truck crossing in surrey
rcmp have worked to divert traffic and
keep the crossing clear however traffic
has occasionally come to a crawl in
parts of the region
well with alberta rapidly winding down
its covet 19 restrictions premier jason
kenney says it's not because of the
ongoing blockade in coots near the
alberta montana border crossing that's
disrupted traffic there for two weeks
the canada border services agency says
services at that port are now
temporarily suspended our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson joins us now
with how premier jason kenney is
responding to the demonstrations
mercedes
chris this week on the west block
premier jason kenney says that he is
sympathetic to the frustrations that so
many canadians feel about covert
regulations but despite that he says no
politician should be promoting blockades
well i i will never praise people who
are out there breaking the law creating
public safety hazards uh and i don't
think anybody in elected office should
do that
that's a different tone than some
federal conservatives have taken
including the frontrunner for the
conservative leadership campaign pierre
polyev who has said that he is proud of
the truckers and has supported the
convoy
while kenny was critical of ottawa's
decision to implement vaccine mandates
for truckers he agrees with prime
minister justin trudeau's position that
government officials should not be
meeting with convoy demonstrators
well frankly no i don't think you
government's elected government should
get into position where they're held
hostage by uh
groups that are uh breaking the law and
hurting others and and violating the
rights of others
i think that these folks have made their
point and they can continue to make
their point in lawful and peaceful ways
without disrupting the economy the lives
of others creating public safety st
hazards
i think it's long past overdue for
enforcement kenny says that his sympathy
for the frustrations of convoy
supporters did not influence his
decision to rapidly lift covid
restrictions in his province we'll have
more with jason kenney tomorrow on the
west block as well as an interview with
the minister for emergency preparedness
in ottawa bill blair back to you chris
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes you can watch the west
block as mercedes mentioned tomorrow
right here on global now french police
clashed with protesters today after a
convoy inspired by canadian rallies made
its way to central paris
police deployed tear gas in some parts
of the french capital as demonstrators
protesting pandemic restrictions
breached police lines officials say
police arrested more than a dozen people
and handed out hundreds of fines
fearing a russian invasion is imminent
the u.s is the latest country to tell
its citizens to leave ukraine canada has
already done so but global affairs says
nearly 800 registered canadians are
still there prime minister trudeau
offered support to ukraine's president
in a phone call today but as jennifer
johnson reports some are urging him to
do more
u.s intelligence reports russia has 80
percent of its forces ready to launch a
full-scale invasion of ukraine
more than 100 000 russian troops are
amassed along ukraine's border and the
rest are on route missiles and other
military equipment are in place too
we're in the window when a russian
invasion can start at any time if
president putin so decides
that includes in the coming days u.s
president joe biden held a high-stakes
call with russian president vladimir
putin saturday urging him to stand down
the u.s embassy is being evacuated only
core diplomatic staff will remain
american citizens are being told to
leave the country too biden is warning
putin not to harm any americans i'm
hoping
that if in fact he's foolish enough to
go in he's smart enough not to in fact
do anything that would negatively impact
non-american citizens
u.s soldiers helping to train ukraine's
army have also reportedly left the
country but an additional 3 000 american
troops are heading to poland joining two
thousand others already deployed to
eastern europe these are not soldiers
who are being sent to go fight russia in
ukraine they're going to defend
nato territory putin is trying to stop
ukraine from joining nato giving an
international military protection the
canadian government is also urging its
citizens to leave ukraine the
ukrainian-canadian congress which
represents roughly 1.4 million canadians
of ukrainian heritage wants the trudeau
government to punish russia immediately
we think that it's time to do some
sanctions today tomorrow the next week
so that putin understands that we're
serious about this and he can face some
consequences if there is an invasion the
u.s and his allies are promising
punishing economic sanctions against
putin and his billionaire backers
blocking financial transactions around
the world for now putin denies he plans
an attack which experts say would have
devastating effects there would be a
very bad humanitarian crisis and loss of
life several world leaders have offered
to negotiate a diplomatic solution to
the situation but putin has rebuffed
those attempts now intense world watches
and waits for what could be the greatest
security crisis between russia and the
west since the cold war
jennifer johnson global news washington
still ahead step by step a breakthrough
for people with spinal cord injuries
scientists are taking a giant step
forward in spinal injury research
published this week in the journal
nature medicine as mike trolley shows us
swiss-based researchers have developed a
spinal implant that's enabling a
paraplegic to walk again
for a man who was told he would never
walk again michelle roccotti sees every
step he's now taking as a gift the
italian man severed his spine in a
motorcycle accident no one as injured as
rokhati has ever walked on their own
again
until now thanks to groundbreaking
research at the beginning i was a little
bit scared
swiss researchers implanted nerve
stimulating devices in the spines of
three men between the ages of 29 and 41.
using a tablet and artificial
intelligence the device sends signals to
the spinal nerves that are responsible
for controlling leg movements
what makes it unique is instead of
sending electrical signals down the
spine it targets the damaged area
directly in a healthy person there is a
message from the brain
going through the spinal cord and then
activating the pool of motor neurons
that are activating certain muscles we
need to relearn it when we do it with
the stimulation it's not that natural
but it becomes more and more natural the
more you train ali
the researchers are quick to point out
their discovery isn't a miracle or a
cure nor is it a surgical fix for spinal
injuries that are still considered
irreparable but they believe with work
it can improve quality of life at the
very beginning
it's not super easy they still need
weight bearing and they need to
understand what's going on
but they can activate immediately their
legs
and and step a trial launch is planned
in the u.s next year with up to 100
patients by then rocati hopes to have
achieved his goal of walking a kilometer
on his own with the walker
i'm free i can walk wherever i want
in this moment
they told me okay now i'm working
microlight global news toronto
an armchair army of gamers helping
scientists solve the biggest mysteries
in medicine next
gamers are skilled at saving fictional
worlds but during the pandemic some have
been given a chance to play a game that
could have an impact on the real world
fight against covet
john hua has more on the program and its
impact john
when the pandemic hit a gaming company
knew it wanted to help in any way it
could
and it had a secret weapon an armchair
army it started here in reykjavik
iceland with the gaming company ccp the
makers of the hugely popular game eve
online they knew with the number of
players in computing power at their
fingertips that could lend a hand in the
fight against coven 19.
so they reached out to the medical
community and were put in touch with
ryan brinkman a scientist at the bc
cancer research center with his help
they were able to create a game where
players try to identify the different
effects of covid on human cells we're
looking for an increase in the amount of
certain cells or a decrease in the
amount of certain cells
the first cell samples used in the game
were taken from patients in northern
italy to have it come in right from
those front lines was a bit of a surreal
thing if you really thought about it
enough but it also was you know a
motivator for us to really push this
thing out
it asks players to try and identify
different cell types using real cell
samples from covet patients
it was something that particularly
appealed to bc gamer mike daw
when project discovery came out for the
covid research i was just about to start
chemotherapy so this was near and dear
to my heart i felt like i was getting
involved with the science that was
affecting the whole planet
in the flow cytometer game players like
michael are tasked with lassoing a group
of dots they believe are the same type
of cell
i can definitely see that there is a
cluster here so i'm doing my best to
outline it
the mini game called project discovery
flow cytometer created within eve online
has been a massive success
gamers have done the equivalent of over
510 years of work identifying over 13
million samples
and all the data they have provided will
be used to create a program to save
scientists even more time in the future
it's information that can help
scientists not only understand covid but
other diseases like cancer
thank you john and you can watch john's
full report tonight at 8 on the new
reality right here on global
and next on global national the 97 year
old swimmer setting records just as
impressive as anything you'll see at the
olympics and her next big goal
betty brussell has loved swimming all
her life but it wasn't until she was in
her 60s that she realized she was really
good at it now 97 she's won countless
medals and broken two world records and
as jay duran shows us betty isn't even
close to the finish line yet
i don't know where these are from you'll
have to forgive betty brussel it's hard
to keep track two fourth she has a bag
full of swim metal she can barely lift
most of them are gold she's usually
standing on top of the podium but what's
really impressive is the fact she didn't
start swimming competitively until she
was 68. i am a late bloomer yes betty
grew up with her 11 siblings just north
of amsterdam that's her on the right
they learned to swim in this canal
taking the plunge any chance they could
get going out at seven o'clock in the
morning before i went to work
and just swam into canal and it man it
was cold
she could never have guessed that one
day she would set two world records at
masters meets pretty good i was quite
happy with that
[Applause]
[Music]
that was really really nice
life's getting busy for betty again
twice a week she drives herself to the
pool to train
there's still a lot of work to do her
goal in life is to make it to a hundred
and to break all the world records in
the 100 to 104 age group
she has suffered a heart attack broke
both feet cracked a vertebra and a bad
fall and had an operation on her
shoulder none of it has stopped her i
always when i'm recovered i go back
i go to rest a little bit too you know
an old lady
quiet time is a little more typical for
someone her age her other hobby isn't
nearly as demanding
but there are still medals to win and
records to break just in case you were
wondering how much longer betty brussell
will keep coming to the pool always
always i feel them
i feel always the best when i'm swimming
jay durant global news
keep on swimming betty that is global
national for this saturday night i'm
chris galas tonight your canada is a
frozen belmont lake in havelock ontario
thanks for watching we'll see you back
here tomorrow night
[Music]
you